Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see magical things that
open up when we are able to automatically find
the foreground and the background of a video.
Let’s see why that matters!
This new technique leans on a previous method
to find the boy, and the dog. Let’s call this
level 1 segmentation. So far so good, but
this is not the state of the art. Yet.
Now, comes level 2 - it also found the shadow
of the boy, and, the shadow of the dog.
Now we’re talking!
But it doesn’t stop there!
It gets even better. Level three, this
is where things get out of hand - look,
the dog is occluding the boy’s shadow,
and it is able to deal with that too.
So, if we can identify all of the effects that
are attached to the boy and the dog, what can
we do with all this information? Well, for
instance, we can even remove them from the video.
Nothing to see here. Now, a common problem
is that still, the silhouette of the subject
still remains in the final footage,
so let’s take a close look together!
I don’t see anything at all. Wow. Do
you? Let me know in the comments below!
Just to showcase how good this removal is, here
is a good technique from just one year ago.
Do you see it? This requires the
shadows to be found manually,
so we have to work with that. And still, in the
outputs, you can see the silhouette we mentioned.
And, how much better is the new method?
Well, it finds the shadows automatically.
That is already mind blowing, and the outputs
are…yes, much cleaner. Not perfect, there is still
some silhouette action, but if I were not actively
looking for it, I might not have noticed it.
It can also remove people
from this trampoline scene,
and not only the bodies, but it also removes
their effect on the trampolines as well. Wow.
And as this method can perform
all this reliably, it opens up
the possibility for new, magical effects.
For instance, we can duplicate this test subject,
and even fade it in and out. Note that it
has found its shadows as well. Excellent!
So, it can deal with finding not only
the shape of the boy and the dog,
and it knows that it’s not enough to just find
their silhouettes, but it also has to find
additional effects they have on the footage.
For instance, their shadows. That is wonderful,
and what is even more wonderful is that this
was only one of the simpler things it could do.
Shadows are not the only
potential correlated effects,
look. A previous method was able to find the
swan here, but that’s not enough to remove it,
because it has additional effects on the scene.
What are those? Well, look, it has reflections,
and it creates ripples too. This is so much
more difficult than just finding shadows.
And now, let’s see the new method..and! Whoa.
It knows about the reflections and ripples,
finds both of them, and gives us this
beautifully clean result. Nothing to see here.
Also, look at this elephant. Removing
just the silhouette of the elephant
is not enough, it also has to
find all the dust around it,
and it gets worse, the dust is changing
rapidly over time. And believe it or not…wow,
it can find the dust too, and remove the
elephant. Again, nothing to see here.
And if you think that this dust was the new
algorithm at its best, then have a look at this
drifting car. Previous method. Yes, that is the
car, but you know what I want. I want the smoke
gone too. That’s probably impossible, right?
Well, let’s have a look. Wow. I can’t believe
it. It grabbed and removed the car and the smoke
together…and, once again, nothing to see here.
So, what are those more magical things
that this opens up? Watch carefully…it
can make the colors pop here. And, remember, it
can find the reflections of the flamingo, so, it
keeps not only the flamingo, but the reflection of
the flamingo in color as well. Absolutely amazing.
And, if we can find the background of a video,
we can even change the background. This works
even in the presence of a moving
camera, which is a challenging problem.
Now, of course, not even this technique is
perfect - look here. The reflections are copied
off of the previous scene,
and it shows on the new one.
So what do you think? What would
you use this technique for?
Let me know in the comments, or if you wish
to discuss similar topics with other Fellow
Scholars in a warm and welcoming environment,
make sure to join our Discord channel. Also,
I would like to send a big thank you to the mods
and everyone who helps running this community.
The link to the server is available in
the video description. You’re invited.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!